Speaker 1: You might be wondering. Trump has an
event at 4 p.m. on a Thursday in New Hampshire.
Who goes to such a speech in the middle of the
workday on a Thursday in New Hampshire? Well,
the great thing is we have video of
who goes there. Let's take a look. They
actually interviewed on right side broadcasting
a young guy who says that Trump inspired him to
maybe run for office one day at school.
They tell him he's right, he's a racist
and sexist. But Trump has inspired this
kid or something like that. Look at this,
The future leaders of America.
Speaker 5: So what's your plan?
You're the year. You're the youngest
one right now. And Connecticut,
where do you see yourself in ten years?
Speaker 1: I know what that means. I'm
the youngest one in Connecticut, but no.
Speaker 3: Well, I got inspired by a man you know
quite well. His name is Donald Trump. And my goal
someday is to get higher up in politics. I don't
really know where that's going to lead me, but I
keep the same principles that he has never give
up, never give in, never back down. And as a young
conservative, I've taken a lot of heat, especially
in school. I've been called all the labels racist,
sexist. I've been yelled at by teachers because
I stood for the Pledge of Allegiance when no
one else would. So I've kind of learned that,
especially in Connecticut, which is a quite
liberal state, you got to stand for what you
believe in. So I'd like to maybe move up and run
for office when I'm done pursuing my education,
you know, get that degree under your belt and
hopefully maybe one day run for a national office.
Speaker 5: That's what you've got
to do. I love busses. Give a good
shot on his outfit here. I love the red pants.
Speaker 1: The kid is wearing a blue suit jacket
that has white stars on it. It's sort of like a
flag version of a suit. I guess I'm going to move
on without any further commentary on this one.
I think it's a minor and just it all is a little
bit icky, but I'll just say that that's really,
really sad. Video. They then interviewed another
individual who I guess is legally an adult, and
this guy says he's an atheist, but he also is a
Christian conservative. Very interesting.
Speaker 2: So if I'm open and honest,
I'm an atheist, but I align more closely with
the Christian conservative worldview. And so
I pretty much support Christian conservatism,
that moral and that whole moral compass. And
so that's what I stand for.
Speaker 1: Yeah, that I mean,
that's that's really sad in that it is so mixed
up and jumbled. I'm an atheist, but the morality
of Christian conservatism strikes me as correct.
Therefore, I am going to support candidates who
actually think that I, as an atheist, should
have a subservient or secondary status to them
because they believe that we should have a
country that is overtly Christian in terms of
civil government. It's all really, really whacked.
Now, here is my favorite moment from this. Okay,
There's an remember ivermectin, one of these cures
that didn't cure nor prevent COVID that was being
floated by many on the right. They have a new
commercial on right side broadcasting. I guess the
guy who recommended ivermectin to Trump has some
supplement that will ward off spike protein, which
they have. There's almost nothing true. But the
funniest part about this is that the broadcaster
on right side broadcasting her diction. Is
so terrible and she barely even understands
what she's reading and at one point refers to
ivermectin as ivermectin. Just I can't imagine
they sold any of these pills based on this ad.
Speaker 6: Protein spike. Protein is the toxic
substance that attaches to your cells to allow
m RNA to enter worse, both COVID and the vaccine
function by using spike proteins to attach to
your cells. Many of us have become overloaded
with excess spike protein from our surroundings
over the past few years and haven't made the
connection between not feeling 100% this it.
Speaker 1: None of this is true. I hope
I want to make really clear none
of this is true. It's a grift on
a grift. On a grift. On a grift.
Speaker 6: That and spike protein
overload. This is a sad reality that
we all have to address. Fortunately,
there is help. The chief Medical board at the
wellness company, including Dr. Peter McCollough,
the doctor that recommended Ivermectin.
Speaker 1: Ivermectin? Remember
when we took ivermectin, guys.
Speaker 6: And hydroxychloroquine to President
Trump back in 2020, as well as renowned epidemics?
Speaker 1: All right, So they're selling a pill
that from the guy who brought you ivermectin.
They have a pill to get rid of spike protein
that you might have absorbed from bananas in the
grocery store. It's just the spike is all in our
environment, which is really, really crazy.
Then they got back to interviewing people.
They found a guy at the Trump rally who
remember the Trump rally was in Manchester,
New Hampshire. He came up from New Jersey
because he believes Trump was sent by God.
Speaker 5: I think it's very important to
support Donald Trump, if not, our nation goes
down. I believe he was sent by God to preserve
Abraham Lincoln's promise that the government
of the people, of the by the people and for the
people will not perish. But I think it's rather
ironic because I remember probably nobody else
knows this this armory in 1976, I was here when
I was in high school. And this here, this is
where Ronald Reagan gave his speech announcing
that he was primary, saying President Ford.
Speaker 1: All right. So a bit of a history
lesson. And then the same guy mentions
that he would also be willing to take a
bullet for Trump and says a lot of the
people at the rally would my support.
Speaker 5: My support of Donald Trump
is unwavering. I would take a bullet
for the man seriously and a lot of us
would. And we're going to fail. If they
wouldn't put it on the ballot, we'd ride him in.
Speaker 1: There you go. Totally normal stuff.
And by the way, let's hope that it is a write in
campaign that somehow Trump loses the primary and
these folks write them in. It would guarantee
that Donald Trump loses. All right, last thing,
and then we're going to move on. Some people
at this rally, just a random lame rally where
Trump gave the same speech he always gives with a
little bit of additional hysteria. People camped
out overnight after driving up from Florida.
Speaker 2: It's boring to ride. 445 is here.
We came I came from Florida.
Speaker 1: 60 at Trump event.
We love Trump. A lot of us come.
Speaker 2: Across the country to
come see the greatest president ever. Donald
J. Trump. That's absolutely true. I'm from
Tennessee. Got here last night, flew in. Oh.
Speaker 5: You guys got here. Was there
anybody else in line or.
Speaker 4: Oh, yeah,
they set up the tent over here and stuff.
It's about 4:00 yesterday, 4:00 here.
Speaker 5: So let's go in here real
quickly. We heard you guys were here
at 4:00 yesterday setting up a tent.
Speaker 2: Where are you from? Where
are you from? A man? I'm from New York City.
Speaker 5: The Bronx. The Bronx came all the
way down here for President Trump, of course.
Speaker 1: All right. So, listen, it's a cult.
We shouldn't for a moment think that the cult
has diminished as we head into 24. What we have
to hope for and push for is that a lot of them
are just bored because politics was just a shiny
object and now they moved on and that others
will be tied up with something else and just
won't be as engaged with the exact same Trump
message that he's been using for six years now,
and that on turnout, we end up preventing
Trump from getting back into the Oval
Office. But if for a second you believe the
hardcore cultists are any less interested,
let those interviews be proof that
that is very, very much not the case